what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome back to comics explained our
Sunday series where I take your
questions and do my best to answer them
for those of you guys who saw the
morning episode you guys know that I was
so exhausted even now like I haven't
gone back and watched it because I'm
sure it's pitiful but I told you guys we
would do around 2 to make up for this
morning so this is round 2 so so a
couple things one of the things I want
to talk about first before we I guess
jump into this before we actually get
into the whole the whole Q&A thing is
first things first down in the
description of the video you will see a
link to a YouTube channel called Kapow
comic books comic book show Kapow comic
book show it's actually ran by this
woman and it's actually a really really
cool show they they deal with like all
different kinds of concepts in in comic
books like gender issues different
things like that but it's really really
cool and and I really enjoyed it
so so check out the link of the
description head over there and and be
like hey guys like how much explains
something over here just want to say
what's up and check out their content
and I think you guys are really gonna
enjoy it the other thing is between the
Deadpool's between Lady Deadpool in head
pool Lady Deadpool takes it so I went
through and I counted the count of the
votes and and I was like okay like Lady
Deadpool is the winner here so the next
video we'll do will be on Lady Deadpool
now because we have kid pool that came
out today and then we had the first part
of the Q&A and the sentence basically
like three videos today we're not doing
a video tomorrow no way like we need to
just take some time in chill so we'll
have the podcasts on Tuesday and then
we'll have probably a video on Tuesday
probably either probably earlier in the
day around 12 o'clock or so and then and
then we'll go from there but I need to
take today and clean my apartment and
I'm gonna get some kotoba after this and
so on and so forth but but anyway so
yeah so so the questions the questions
that you guys have the questions are
already rolling in like it's it's
amazing like like people are just like
oh my god Rob's here here's a question
it's it's funny to me yes
charge [ __ ] accan 909 yes I just look
at the questions you guys are asking in
the chat and I do my best to answer them
if your question doesn't get answered
then just ask your question again don't
like spam your question calmly but ask
it again and I try to answer as many
questions as I can it's just it's a
little difficult to do sometimes just
because they'll become a point where
they're just be so many questions coming
in that it'll be it'll be tough to see
but anyway so what's your opinion on the
new DC costumes see we talked about this
in the last one that last one we did and
and the new DC's like the DC costumes
are kind of a funny thing to me I never
understood all the hype around costumes
now there are some costumes that are
like mainstays like Superman's costume
Batman's costumes spider-man's costume
the Punishers casting those costumes are
mainstays like those costumes are
directly linked they are forever linked
with those characters to me for the most
part costumes don't really matter um I
wouldn't say I'm a stickler I guess it's
wrong to say they don't really matter I
would say I'm not a stickler for
costumes um I'm not one that really gets
a little irritated about costumes I
think that refreshing the costumes is a
great way to refresh the characters if
you can't change the basis of a
character that is to say if Superman is
from the time he was made until Tommy
appeared and Superman number one with
his origin story all the way up until
the current day if he's forever going to
be the survivor the last survivor of the
planet Krypton that was blown up and
he's gonna wear the blue outfit with the
red underwear and he's gonna wear the
red cape then at the very least he can
change his costume up a bit in order to
make things a little more fresh to take
away the stale nature the same thing
with Batman
not to a degree that is extreme I mean I
remember remember when not what was it I
think was after the death of Superman
they revamped his character and call him
the man of energy and everyone hated and
people who didn't even read comic books
hated it people who read comic books
hated it so of course that's a little
too extreme but nonetheless just one of
those one of those things I'm not a huge
stickler for word but you know in the
end I think it's I think it's personal
preference so um let's see
do you like the squad of bears then do
you like the spider Gwyn run
my opinions is I like it honestly when I
was going through and I was reading
spider-verse
and I saw a spider Duane she wasn't
interesting enough to me that I even
wanted to pick up her trade it wasn't it
was just kind of like I mean but see
here's the deal guys when it comes to
like spider-man spider-man related
characters I'm just not a big fan I'm
not huge on the spider verse I didn't
really have been it's just never really
something that stuck with me I like
cosmic level characters I like super
powerful characters but I also like
characters that are relatable to me in
spider-man's not he's just not really a
relatable character for me so I've never
really enjoyed it too much it looks like
I'm lip-syncing what would I be
lip-syncing I guess I'm lip-syncing my
thoughts the Power Stone versus World
War Hulk who wins all the Power Stone
hands down because remember the Power
Stone is infinite well I guess seem
credible hopes infinite ooh but no even
with like the tone down even like tone
down if Thanos was easily able to
overpower the Hulk I mean it was it was
pretty I think yeah the Power Stone
would allow Thanos to destroy planets it
would allow him to annihilate almost
like nearly immortal beings I'm pretty
sure he could take out the Incredible
Hulk let's see why has Peter Parker why
was Peter Parker alright don't don't
cuss in the chat guys um
Lloris Peter Parker so dumb for taking
his mask off in Civil War no one told
him to do that
well alright see here here's the big
deal alright for those of you guys who
are wondering why spider-man is such a
big stickler in civil war those of you
guys who want to know why spider-man has
to be in Civil War or at least for those
of us who are comic book fans the
spider-man's role in Civil War was
relatively confined with the exception
of one thing the one moment in Civil War
they gave spider-man such a huge
standing with regards to spider-man fans
and Civil War fans was because he
publicly revealed his identity for the
first time that was the first time
spider-man had actually come out taking
off his mask in front of the cameras and
said my name is Peter Parker and I've
been spider-man since I was 15 years old
it was a huge moment I mean I can't tell
you how huge that was in comic books in
spider-man comics the whole nine yards
it was massive it was
he'd reveal that's one of the reasons
why civil war is so big now the reason
spider-man did that was to give credence
to Tony Stark's registration because
spider-man has the most guarded identity
people still know yeah there's still no
coffee we'll have coffee one day people
still know that or I guess people knew
that spider-man's identity was the most
guarded identity of anybody in Marvel
Comics there was pretty much no one
outside of a handful of people who knew
that spider-man was Peter Parker and so
when he came out and revealed it
publicly it was saying I believe enough
in Tony Stark's plan for registration
that I'm willing to reveal myself I
believe that one I'll be protected
because my identity will be public but
also have the backing of the government
everything will be fine
but the other half is he's coming out in
support of it now what we saw after that
was pretty much anything but the
spider-man was targeted almost
immediately after his identity was
revealed he was that almost shot like
right off the bat it was it was crazy
but nonetheless am i enjoy you superior
Iron Man oh yeah superior Iron Man is a
great story um I love superior Iron Man
because it feels like I'm reading a
comic book adaptation of Iron Man for
the model Cinematic Universe I mean he's
kind of rambunctious again we're really
really new into superior Iron Man which
will do superior Iron Man explained
because Marvel is wrapping that up in
April like they're gonna in that in
April or the very least they're gonna in
the solo run of superior Iron Man they
might bring him back but it's gonna be a
totally separate thing but we'll
probably touch on axis at least we'll
have to I think Vinnie's doing axes so I
may point to Benny with regards to the
axis axis event I know he's doing Civil
War and I think he's pointing to me so I
think I think it's only fair dat to
point to him for axis but superior Iron
Man comes out of comes out of access for
those of you guys who were unaware
it's the inversion of people's I guess
their perspectives or their role
superheroes are they like good guys
become bad guys bad guys become good
guys and that kind of stuff but
nonetheless um I love I love the
superior Iron Man story so far it's it's
a great break away from I'm Tony Stark
and I'm constantly butting heads with
Captain America and I'm trying to do the
right thing but I'm screwing up the
process like right now Tony Stark's like
you know I don't care like I'm gonna do
what I want when I want how I want and
I'm gonna charge people $100 a day to
look beautiful which is an awesome cons
Secret Wars our convergence I'm actually
excited about both I'm excited about
convergence because it'll give me a
chance to go back and again look at a
lot of the older stories and DC Comics
but I'm really interested to see what's
gonna come out of it like what the
universe is gonna look like post
convergence and Secret Wars I'm excited
about not necessarily for the same
reasons I'm just excited to see the
Marvel reboot I want to see what happens
after Secret Wars is over which i think
is most most everybody's like that
there's really only a handful of stories
in Secret Wars that really really
interest me the years of Future Passed
x-men 92 different things like that like
that sounds sounds really interesting to
me I think hold on a second guys finish
them yeah message real quick we can try
it okay
anyway um but yeah I think it'll I think
it'll be it'll be cool I'll be reading
both I mean this is comics explained you
know we got to cover both convergence
and and Marvel comics so and for those
of you guys well I guess we'll answer it
at the at the end of this but um I guess
I'll ask that at the end of it but
anyway um let's see what do I think
about the Suicide Squad movie okay I'm
actually really really interested in a
Suicide Squad movie but here's the
question that we have to ask are they
gonna use the Amanda Waller Suicide
Squad or are they gonna use the later
iterations of Suicide Squad mm-hmm
because the original Suicide Squad was
called the Suicide Squad because they
were taking on missions that were deemed
to be suicidal that nobody could survive
it I'm actually interested to see if
they're gonna use use like that same
thing or if this is just DC's way of
saying hey guys like we have some really
popular characters and comic books so
let's just throw them all on a screen
and see what happens like I'm really
hoping they don't do that because taking
a gamble like that could be disastrous
and so I'm really hoping it doesn't have
to be that way um let's go to Twitter
for a second and see if anybody's asking
anything on Twitter sometimes I do
sometimes they don't but most people
just show up in the chat and ask
questions so no nobody's asking anything
on Twitter which makes sense people just
show up in the chat and like hey here's
a question and they ask they ask
questions what is convergence
convergence is DC consolidating their
multiverse down into its it
similar to crisis on Infinite Earths but
it's a way for DC to bring back some
older stories but to basically give
those fans who felt upset about the new
52 about the casting aside of the older
continuity pre new 52 in DC Comics a
chance to see some of those stories
retold a chance to see those stories
again now whether or not those stories
will continue on after convergence is
something we don't know here's a really
good example um in the 1960s I think was
1963 DC gave us earth to in a story
called flash of two worlds and this was
when Barry Allen met Jay Garrick and it
was DC saying that the Golden Age
superhero still exists it was the first
time we saw the multiverse in DC Comics
going forward we saw the I guess the the
earth 2 continuity continuing on and
kind of doing its own thing in addition
to the main DC continuity now what this
also did is a spawned out a whole bunch
of uh I guess else world stories and
multiverse stories alternate realities
things like that but earth 2 came to an
end I believe with crisis on Infinite
Earths and then they brought it back
because a lot of people really loved
earth 2 and so they started doing earth
2 again and so leading up now we have
earth 2 worlds end I think and that's
one of the events that's supposed to
lead to the destruction of Earth 2 with
regards to secret war I'm sorry with the
convergence but we might say come back
so we're not really sure what's going on
Josh um what do I think is the best
animated comic movie um it's actually a
toss-up like I've been watching a lot of
DC animated films which I knew they were
out there I just didn't really know
where to watch them at and so I went out
and got a few of them and I think that
under the Red Hood is probably the best
one they have and I would say that the
Doctor Strange one is really really
solid for Marvel those are two of my
favorite why onslaught I don't know what
you mean wouldn't meanwhile on any new
characters for civil war that we haven't
seen yet that will show you that I think
will show up I don't think so Civil War
encompass to everybody so if they're
gonna reduce civil war in Secret Wars I
have no idea what they're gonna do here
I have no idea how this story is gonna
unfold what I'm really hoping they don't
do is say hey guys like here's Secret
Wars Civil War now if you want to catch
up on everything that's leading into
this go buy the secret war go buy Civil
War that's there be a terrible idea
I'm hoping they don't do that because
that would make a disastrous people just
wouldn't probably wouldn't check it out
it wouldn't be very popular but
nonetheless you know I think of the I
think that they're gonna continue on
with the idea we saw pretty much all the
superheroes with the exception of the
Incredible Hulk and Doctor Strange
involved in civil wars so mmm the goatee
is pretty good
the goatees keep it on keep it on let's
see what if instead of Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch being Inhumans the whole
time they release the Terrigen mist on
the mutants on the oops well I just lost
the question oh um on the mutants and
they get new powers and become inhuman
anyway alright that wouldn't happen
that's that's not how that works um all
the Terrigen mists do is activate a
latent in human gene that's really all
it does I mean it's it's it's that's and
and mutants just become mutants because
they're X gene just activates
automatically what's that usually once
they reach puberty when their body
starts going through chemical changes
and begins to change physically and they
begin to change emotionally the the X
gene activates so onslaught versus
apocalypse to see people ask that
question all the time it's like it's it
cracks me up people ask that question
onslaught wins that argument hands down
and the reason why I know is because
during the onslaught saga The Watcher
was standing alongside apocalypse an
onslaught was wreaking havoc pretty much
laying waste to everybody that fought
him and and the watcher was was like
dude you should really like we need to
talk about the flash the washer was like
dude you really need to put your
intellect in your powers to destroy
onslaught because if you don't he's
gonna wipe all of them out and then he's
gonna kill you and then he's gonna
destroy the world and then he's gonna
move on to the universe
and it's gonna be really bad and so
apocalypse was like yeah you're probably
right and so he sided with cable and
they tried to fight um they try to find
onslaught they didn't win they ended up
entering like I guess finding onslaught
on the in the god I camera what that's
called now what do they call that you
guys know what I'm talking about in the
mind a place in the mind world I don't
remember what is I don't know what it's
called
anyway um let's see okay so the flash so
let's talk about the flash for a second
let's talk about the flash TV show
because the flash TV show has just like
taken off like it is I guess you know no
pun intended but it is is really really
taken off see this this is one of the
problems that I had with a flash TV show
is they spend so long like leading up to
this they spend so long like I guess
coming to grips with this thing like hey
guys like we have the flash TV show and
like professor zoom reverse flash as
part of this but we're gonna spend like
a season and a half leading up to it
that drove me up the wall like it drove
me nuts so bad but they finally come out
and said okay yes professor zoom is dr.
whatever his name is the dude that's
been helping very on that was pertaining
to be crippled the whole time I'm
terrible with names but in any event
they said yes he's professor zoom yes
he's the reverse-flash and yes for some
reason or another he has it out for you
now what was really really cool is they
said that when he when he attacked
what's his name when he attacked the
sidekick the guy that looks like the
dude from Twilight when when he attacked
him he was like in my century like
you're dead so that tells us one that
that Thawne is from the few from the
future that he is from you know
centuries into the future which my
question is this is it gonna play out
the same way it does in the comics where
he was obsessed with Barry Allen where
he went back in past when that game in
the past and even like tried to replace
Barry Allen for a while he's gonna try
to do that here um the difference is
that in the comics he actually had
himself surgically altered to look like
Barry Allen of course that hasn't
happened so I'd be kind of interested to
see how all this plays out the astral
plane there we go thank you it seems
like what they're going to do is we're
basically just going to say hey like for
whatever reason he hates you
and he's just gonna try to like kill you
I'm not really sure either way they've
basically set it up for the flashpoint
event and we had talked about this in
the the podcast this morning now the
really cool thing about what they're
doing with the flash TV show is they're
basically giving themselves an out there
saying that if things get to a point
where by the writing me gets to go down
but or I guess maybe for some reason
they want to roll everything over into a
single continuity they can just launch
the flashpoint event and they can say
okay guys starting now everything's a
single continuity and just take it from
there and it would it would make sense
just because those who read comics
understand it and they would write it in
a way hopefully that it would all make
sense
so Cisco yeah he looks at the dude from
Twilight I mean I don't know what to
tell you um but anyway uh who's my
favorite mutant my favorite mutant is
Franklin Richards because he's just so
damn powerful because he's capable of so
much um let's see what superhero movies
are you looking forward to
um oh God guardians of the galaxy - I'm
looking forward to ant-man
I think ant-man it's gonna be ant-man is
gonna feel like The Incredible Hulk
alright in the sense that we know the
incredible hoax part of the Marvel
Universe
Marvel Cinematic Universe but no one
really talks about it people are like
there's kind of this outlier over there
like here's the inner circle of normal
Cinematic Universe films and then
there's the Incredible Hulk over there
which i guess is because of the way
Edward Norton treated Marvel because of
the the breakup between the two of them
because of how everyone one conducted
himself assuming that what the rumor
mill was churning out was actually true
a lot of people I think had a distaste
for the movie as a whole because I think
they think it could have been better
which in truth it was Marvel's you know
second foray into films I'm pretty sure
it came after the Incredible Hulk Rama
came came after I oh man let me double
check it make sure cuz I've got a list
of the films of the Marvel movies that
have been released to us for us to check
out yeah I'm in the Incredible Hulk so
it came right after Iron Man so they
were really it was in the early days of
of them producing films and so I think
if they had a chance to make a sequel if
they chose to make a sequel if they
chose to reboot it it would be much
better but I think it'd still be I think
it'd still be pretty solid um if I make
a draw my life it should be it should
just be called Rob explained I'm not
gonna make a draw my life
I don't know how I don't know how to do
that I think it'd be kind of cool but I
have no idea how to do that um let's see
and do I think of interest who is going
to kill Hulk and kill him as in cinnamon
to space yeah probably
um here's a problem Incredible Hulk The
Incredible Hulk costs boatloads of money
for them to have in a film and they have
it cuz they have Disney money but the
fact remains that if they can find a way
to remove the Incredible Hulk from the
Marvel landscape which it sounds like
they're shaking things up in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but if they can
remove him for the model Cinematic
Universe landscape for say two or three
movies and then bring him back with the
Infinity Gauntlet or the infinity war
that would save them a ton of money and
it could also be done in a way that
makes sense they could just set him off
to a distant planet now here's a problem
that people would have if the illuminati
said or if the avengers said you know
what like The Incredible Hulk was just
too dangerous we're just gonna send them
off to another planet people are gonna
say well I mean what what what goes on
with that like what what happens there
and they're gonna want to know about the
Planet Hulk storyline and so they'd have
to do it in a different way they would
have to do it in a way where the
Incredible Hulk is somehow just I don't
know so they would have to be done I
have to be written away to where it
makes sense
which way or the Incredible Hulk could
be removed from the Marvel Cinematic
Universe martyr Reed Richards or Doctor
Doom see that's a problem they go back
and forth my depending on the writer
sometimes Reed Richards is smarter like
in the origin story for Doctor Doom the
Reed Richards had told dr. doom hey man
like your calculations are off by like a
decimal or two and you may end up
getting yourself killed and doom said no
my works perfect and then the thing
exploded um but actually see here's that
here was a kicker the problem is in that
initial origin story Reed Richards came
off smarter and I guess it came off more
intelligent that's smarter and Ed
Brubaker's books of doom doom actually
travelled to hell and saw what's his
name Saul Mephisto and so I guess what
anyway whichever book it was um he saw
Mephisto and so doom wasn't wrong doom
was right it's just the thing also
exploded so the problem is is kind of a
toss-up it really just depends on the
writer that's one of those things I
can't give you a definitive answer
on whose writer because mom I guess
who's a who's smarter whose writer who's
smart or who's more intelligent because
Marvel just hasn't come out and said
which one of the two is more intelligent
than the other so I will say this though
Doctor Doom created the time machinery
Richards hasn't so see well I mean it's
a Q&A why wouldn't I answer your
question why would you show up to my Q&A
and think that I wouldn't answer your
question can you explain Game of Thrones
no that's coming book role 19 um I don't
do Game of Thrones will I'll be picking
up any convergence tie-ins and if so
which ones um see that's the thing a lot
of the convergence tie-ins look good to
me I'll probably pick up pretty much all
of them I mean it's gonna be 40 stories
I'll probably pick pretty much pick up
all of them at the very least I don't
know it's it's it's really hard to tell
I don't know what all the convergence
titles are going to be and so on now
okay now here's my question I guess
maybe I should ask this are you talking
about the post convergence titles like
the ones are gonna be relaunching which
convergence is over or are you gonna be
talking about the conversion story
itself because it's gonna be 42 issue
stories so clue that up for me like like
answer that question for me then I'll
tell you what my answer is
do I want to see a Star Wars Marvel
crossover yes I want to see Darth Vader
fighting like Darth Vader vs Doctor Doom
how beasts would that be the two of them
fighting each other that would be
absolutely amazing hmm how do I read
comics usually print or digital I have
Marvel unlimited so I usually read them
digitally well I do a Hydra Bob now I'm
not gonna do a Hydra by a question Rob
what is your opinion of Wally West's
pre-fitted to run because of my opinion
I miss Wally West so so much new 52
sucks
give me back the real Wally West well it
makes sense with him bringing back Barry
Allen for the new 52 because he was the
original flash or whenever the original
flash he was he was the flash that I
guess launched the flash into popularity
you had you know Jay Garrick but Jay
Garrick was DISA
for the Golden Age Barry Allen came
along and said hearken last flash and
then we got Kid Flash Wally West and so
on and so forth but nonetheless
um I think Wally West is one of the more
popular versions of the flash I think he
was well I think he he was a character
that a lot of people grew up with but I
think that when you're talking about who
it was that made the flash popular who
it was that made the flash a staple
character that everybody came to know
and love who it was and made the flash
so great but Wally West could then take
over the role of being the flash I think
you're talking about very Allen and so I
think you know DC really had no choice
but to bring back a day Barry Allen for
for DVD two but nonetheless I think well
he wants was a great flash she was
hilarious flash he was a fantastic
character I'd love to see him come back
during conversions and post conversions
I think it'd be a great idea to have two
versions of the flash but nonetheless
you know I think that uh I don't think
they'll do that any comic
recommendations well depends on what
you're interested in and it depends on
what you want to do if what you're
looking to do is to get into to find out
secret Wars to learn about secret Wars
then you want to read time runs out
which is Jonathan Hickman's run on
Avengers and new Avengers and you can
just type in Jonathan Hickman who but
we'll cover time runs out before secret
war starts but nonetheless that's that's
that's where you want to go from here in
truth because of what's happening with
secret Wars there's really no point in
reading the old stories I would say go
with Secret Wars and then once Secret
Wars is over decide what you want to do
if you want to keep going with the newer
stories if you want to read the newer
stories and the older stories or what
because I think some of the older
stories have this special place in the
hearts of a lot of people but I think a
lot of those folks who are getting in a
comics now I want to know about all the
hype they want to know what is the big
deal about Infinity Gauntlet why was the
story so huge what's the big deal about
Civil War why is everybody like oh my
god another bringing civil war back for
secret Wars you know my god Kathryn
America's gonna be based on Civil War
you know I think a lot of people want to
know about that kind of stuff and so I
think that's there's definitely a place
for a lot of those older stories but if
you want to get into the current thing
on on on secret Wars and Marvel Comics
then definitely get into get into
Jonathan's run out of injures and new
Avengers now and that being said DC
Comics
DC Comics is straightforward they've
they rebooted with new 52 so the new 52
continuity as it exists now we'll
continue after convergence there will be
some shaking up will be some changes but
the origin stories of the characters
will remain the same so if you want to
get into DC comics just pick your poison
and jump in the new 52 and that's that's
pretty much where you go um let's see
it's franklin richards the most powerful
person and marvel no not by a longshot
let's see well I explained old man Logan
um yeah probably at some point do you
think it's a good worst film whatever
happened if so how do you think it will
be executed now Secret Wars would be now
they couldn't do Secret Wars you're
talking about way too many characters
that Marvel doesn't have the rights to
in the film's you're talking about the
introduction of a litany another I
couldn't see Secret Wars happening maybe
a super expensive film to pull off it'd
be cool if it did but I don't I don't
think it'll happen what's my favorite
run of the x-men definitely Chris
Claremont run of the x-men all 17 years
of it
I haven't read every single issue of
Chris Claremont running the x-men but as
one of the x-men is definitely the the
best one of the X but now that being
said honorable mentions um let's see
Grant Morrison's run of the x-men is a
really really good one Joss Whedon's run
of the x-men was a really really good
one and that's pretty much it
oh oh hell Greg Pak um x bin volume
volume 2 issue number wine-like
that's a that's a must so let's see how
do I feel about the Age of Apocalypse
the old one the Age of Apocalypse was a
great story but it's just not relevant
anymore so well
I'll take that back I guess they'll be
retelling it with Secret Wars here's
what we might do with Secret Wars with
those stories if they're gonna reach hel
Age of Apocalypse what we might do is
because I'm not gonna go through the
whole Age of Apocalypse thing cuz a lot
of those stories just don't matter but
what we might do is we'll do the Age of
Apocalypse and Secret Wars because I
don't know how many issues that's gonna
be and then we may just continue on I
don't know because Secret Wars is six
months it's it's if I understood Oh
Benny told me correctly Secret Wars is
six months of stories so years of Future
Passed
is six months Age of Apocalypse is six
months Infinity Gauntlet I think is
gonna be six months of stories at least
I hope it's not gonna be six months a
story maybe it will be I'm not really
sure but nonetheless um I think I think
yeah god I don't know we will have our
work cut out for us like like that's
that's gonna be for sure alright let's
see where is the ultimate ultimate
nullifier currently in the comics do you
think it can be used to beat the
beyonders um the ultimate univer or the
ultimate nullifier can wipe out
realities but I don't think you can wipe
out the beyonders per se oh I'm thinking
what not the beyonders per se they're
simply just too powerful for it the
ultimate nullifier as far as I
understand it it was wielded by one of
the mindless ones during original sin
and then that's the last we saw of it I
mean we haven't seen it since I don't
think that's the problem the ultimate
nullifier there's been no fire pops up
like it was really really big in the 90s
like oh my god the ultimate nullifier as
everybody has it it was really big in
the 90s but then the ultimate nullifier
just kind of took a backseat which just
makes sense because if you have a device
they can just destroy realities it was
created by Galactus like do you really
want to have everybody being able to use
it so let's see
which superpower would you like to have
PS just one oh really just one then I'd
like the ability to have every
superpower no I would be mimic if I
could only have one power it would be
mimic and mimic have the power to copy
everybody's powers so that's that's what
I would do
does watcher exists in the MC you see
people say Stanley's The Watcher that's
really just more fanfare than anything
else but I think it'd be a cool idea if
he was The Watcher let's see oh my god
let's see I'm trying to figure out what
question I want to answer cuz there's so
many that are coming in who's your
favorite Batman rider Oh Scott Schneider
hands down Scott Snyder is scott
Snyder's work on Batman has been the
best run of Batman since Frank Miller's
standalone story of Batman like it's you
know it's it's it's some of the best
riding that I've ever seen in the Batman
stories it's dark it's gritty there's a
big difference between his run and Frank
Miller's I don't think his run is as it
doesn't have the same kind of ambience
that Frank Miller's did but it's still a
fantastic series it's still a fantastic
story and in in the Batman con you like
what he's doing so far Batman in game is
amazing Batman eternal is really really
good night of the owls was was not as
stellar as quarter the owls not of the
elves just wasn't as good I felt like
quarter the owls because I mean the
whole thing is one big thing like the
court of the owls but people will
differentiate by calling it court of
owls and night of elves but um the court
of the owls was great because of what
happened with Batman nine of the owls it
felt like Scott's night it was like okay
how do we end this and he just like
won't we'll just write a story about
Batman fighting in their towns and
that's it it just wasn't that great but
it's an important aspect of the
continuity especially getting into
endgame and why does the Joker's
targeting Batman and the bad
family in the first place let's see well
I come to Connecticut comic-con just for
you I don't know if I'd go all the way
to Connecticut for one person but I
think it'd be fun to visit Connecticut
and be kind of cool
how will daredevil tie in to movies we
don't know I have a feeling that
daredevil will tie into the movies in it
see that's that's a great thing about
Netflix Netflix is a great place
introduce characters but they just don't
want to make movies on and order just
one worth investing the time to make a
movie on I think we'll see references to
what goes on in the films in the Netflix
series in the same way you see
references and agents of shield but I
don't know um
I don't know I think it'd be interesting
I think that he can I think it'll tie in
quite well I think it'll it'll make
sense the way that they do it my
thoughts is that in some capacity he'll
be included in civil war he'll be
mentioned a civil war he'll be seen in
civil war something like that they'll
talk about some guy running around
Hell's Kitchen beating people up with a
nightstick like I think that's the kind
of thing that they'll do but I'm not
really sure so let's see the Hulk or
Squirrel Girl a Squirrel Girl
definitely she's never been defeated
like she's probably the greatest
greatest superhero of all time Squirrel
Girl versus the ivory kings I don't know
if she'd survive that
ah let's see which do you think is
better muffles the hand or DC's League
of Shadows ooh oh my god see I'm not
really sure I mean you're you're I mean
the groups are very similar I mean the
hand is just like this really whole
Japanese group that even ran like Hydra
for a while the League of Shadows is
there a group of assassins I mean
they're both two groups of assassins man
the League of Shadows I think is
probably better because they're darker
because DC does darker things in their
comics sometimes and Marvel does I
haven't read a lot of the trades that
involved the League of Shadows I know of
them
but I think that the problem with the
hand is they've basically been
squandered by Marvel over the years when
they could have had really really cool
stories he could have had great concepts
the only thing we really saw with
regards to any story that was halfway
decent was stories that involved Jessica
drew and they weren't even really that
decent at all so you know I don't know
imagine the terror miss affected
Squirrel girls yeah she'd girl at these
great big huge long talons on her hands
and like turn into a giant squirrel and
kill people
let's see which one what character do
you want to have a movie that doesn't in
the MCU hmm let's see which Marvel
character do you one doesn't have a
movie already probably The Punisher but
I want to see a really dark like rated
our Punisher movie coming from Marvel
but we probably won't see that because
they're a Disney Company and Disney
wants to make sure they've reached the
largest number of people possible which
just makes good business sense and they
probably end up going with with pg-13
which wouldn't do the The Punisher
justice if the Punisher were really
gonna appear in the MCU he'd have to
have his own his own Netflix series
which he should because
we'll be awesome Justice League vs
Avengers who wins Oh God
I got to give it to the Justice League
on this one you got some great
characters on the Avengers but the
Justice League I think would take that
hands down it just makes the most sense
to me
I mean you got the Green Lantern you got
Superman you got Batman and all his
gadgets and his intelligence you've got
the flash you've got move Martian
Manhunter I mean let's take like the
creme de la creme of the Justice League
and pit them against the Avengers that's
my question okay you guys answer that
question for me if you could pick the if
you could go through all the members of
the Justice League and all the members
of the Avengers and you could so like to
the five the top five out of each of
those groups and pit them against each
other then who wins you've got a list
your top five and you got to tell me who
wins this is gonna spam the hell out of
the chat all right now let's see since
Marvel is introducing so many new
characters do you think all of them will
appear in infinity war yeah probably
I think infinity Wars can be marvel's
way of basically allowing a bunch of
contracts to end if if Chris Hemsworth
doesn't want to play Thor anymore then
they're gonna kill him off in infinity
war if Chris Chris Evans does want to
play Captain America anymore they're
gonna kill him off in infinity war I
think that's this is gonna be their way
to consolidate a lot of the contractors
are coming to an end get rid of the
characters I don't want to come back and
and move forward with a new batch of
stories after that which is really gonna
be a gamble um I I really couldn't say I
have a whole lot of faith in that
succeeding but I can't say that I
believe it wouldn't succeed I'm actually
just not sure what direction that would
take if that's the direction they chose
Nova in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
are we talking about Richard Ryder or
Sam Alexander because Richard Ryder
would be a great character but Richard
Ryder's old guard Sam Alexander is a
great character for new people getting
into the character of Nova he's a great
Nova he's not not the worst Nova ever
but he's still pretty decent oh all
right totally quit spam in the chat um
let's see Galactus vs. The Watcher who
would win
um Galactus I'm pretty sure I mean
that's I'm pretty sure Galactus would
win he probably destroy the watcher see
which Marvel character would you put in
the DCU and vice versa
um yeah which mom will care to what I
put in the DCU hmm that's a tough one
probably the Punisher I would love to
see how Frank Castle does against
characters like like Batman or if he
were going after the Green Lantern could
he kill him could he could he succeed in
killing them could he find a way to kill
Superman could he actually realize that
he could shoot Superman with a with a
kryptonite bullet he could he killed Lex
Luthor I mean would like something be
able to withstand the the onslaught of
the rampage of of the Punisher those
those would be an interesting series of
stories I would love to see that
Punisher versus the DC Universe that
would be pretty pretty awesome be
stranger I appreciate it man let's see
what's up Rob after seeing the short
glimpse of Quicksilver from age of
Ultron which Quicksilver do you think
will be better I don't know it's hard to
tell we have the film version of
Quicksilver in Days of Future past I'll
have to wait till a movie comes out to
be honest I try not to compare the two
of them I think they're probably gonna
be respectable in their own right
the the Quicksilver in Days of Future
past was actually less hokey than I
thought it was gonna be I thought it was
gonna be a goofy character I thought it
was gonna be stupid like him running
around I thought it was gonna look
stupid but it actually looked pretty
good so I don't know I think it'd be
pretty decent either way I'll see
Rob Rob Rob Rob if you could be a
superhero supervillain for the day which
would you be Marvel or DC please answer
my question I would be hmm which
superhero would I be in Marvel or DC I'd
be the flash I think it'd be awesome to
be able to run around so fast to think
of super speed to move a super speed I
mean I think it would be who I would
want to be Superman because I think it'd
be dumb to be virtually godlike for a
day because I think it'd get boring
really fast but being able to move a
super speed I think would be awesome
which super villain should have their
own movie Lex Luthor I think of Lex
Luthor had his own movie and it was done
right and it was done intelligently by a
really good director and I'm saying like
the Coen brothers or something like that
I think it could be also he could just
be you know the rise of Lex Luthor and
it would be a fantastically done film it
could be slow methodical focus on Lex
Luthor himself on his character develop
Lex Luthor as a character the next
person I'd say after that would be
Magneto but it would have to be based on
Magneto's Greg I'm sorry but by uh an
EFI based on Greg packs magneto
Testament which was a fantastic story
for those of you guys who never read it
it was an unbelievable story let's see
hey Rob somehow I missed the Marvel
one-shot all hail the king and just
watched it how do you think they can
work the real Mandarin into the MCU hmm
see that's the kicker we haven't seen
anything to indicate that the Mandarin
is operating in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but we haven't focused on Asia
either see that's the kicker if you guys
notice there's locations that Marvel
hasn't said anything about Marvel has a
focus on Wakanda on the the on Africa as
a continent as a whole
Marvel hasn't focused on Asia Marvel's
largely been focused on the middle II
and the moon and North America the
reason why they're focused on the Middle
East is because it allowed them to tell
the origin story of Tony Stark it
allowed the or the story of Iron Man one
to play out when they focused on North
America that's for obvious reasons what
Conda and Africa will focus on black
panther Asia will allow them to focus on
the Mandarin now all they could
basically say is the Mandarin was just
this warlord that exists in Asia and he
caught the attention of the guy who was
in who was pretending to be him when he
was issuing those those broadcast Tony
Stark that we're making worldwide news
that could basically be something like
that's the way they could introduce this
way they did with it with the one shot
when they told Sir Ben Kingsley that the
Mandarin wanted to meet him so so I
don't know it could just be that the
Mandarin is like in an entity like he's
some sort of disembodied spirit that
inhabits bodies every every so often
like he just jumps from human hosts to
human hosts whenever the current host of
these in begins to get old and he has to
jump to a new body he may jump into Sir
Ben Kingsley we don't really know they
may not do it they may never introduce
us to the man but they may just kind of
say hey guys here's a tip of the hat to
all you Ironman fans and then leave it
at that and never go back to it again I
don't know let's see which character
from Marvel would you have coffee and
read comics with and what would you
discuss I would have I would read comics
and have coffee with with beasts with
Hank McCoy because he's really really
smart and I think we could have really
cool debates about stuff opinion on
motion comics I think motion comics are
cool they could be disastrous at times
but I think motion comics are a cool
idea like there's um there's a whole
thing on YouTube of Superman red Sun
which is a motion comic and it is
awesome the way it's done the voices and
the whole effect it's it's really really
cool I'll definitely check it out if you
guys ever get a chance let's see do I
think Thor 3 would be a good movie uh
yeah Thor Ragnarok I think it's gonna be
an awesome movie um Rob you would be
fantastic if you could answer this
question who deserves a white ring in
the Marvel Universe I think
Oh God you're talking about in the
Lantern Corps right like the white
lantern [ __ ] who deserves the ring of
life or a ring of life I guess Groot but
give it to Rocket Raccoon that would be
hilarious or give it to give it to the
Punisher because he'd never use this he
would withhold it like he would just
refuse to use it just out of spite
like he would walk around and be like I
have this ring of life but I'd never use
it because I don't want to thanks a lot
Ryan I appreciate it
let's see Rob what do you think about
the new daredevil Netflix series hype or
not oh I'm definitely buying into the
hype I think it's gonna be a great
Netflix series let's see what will the
end credits scene of age of Ultron be oh
definitely spider-man it's gonna be
spider-man related I mean with the news
of spider-man joining the MCU being this
big I mean you got to have you got to
have an in credit scene equal to the
hype of age of Ultron and not and
spider-man we're definitely equal that I
would hope so like I can guarantee as
soon as they got the rights to put
spider-man in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I'm not a universe and a film
of their choosing and as soon as that
hit the news as soon as they hit the
presses and it blew up oh dude
Marvel was - they went to work getting
some kind of post-credit scene for the
age of ultron featuring spider-man
getting sorted out I can almost
guarantee you that if I'm wrong I would
be surprised which I guess maybe I
shouldn't be because I'm wrong a lot so
anti-monitor versus Thanos with the
Infinity Gauntlet who would win uh
I think a better answer to that question
or I guess a better version would be
anti-monitor versus Thanos with the
heart of the universe because of the
heart of the universe Thanos ended
reality it'd be a draw
I mean ante monitor was wiping out
universes and Thanos could wipe out
universes with the heart of the gala
heart of the universe
I don't know it'd be hard to tell
Deadpool with a black ring oh my god
could you imagine that
let's see Rob don't be that guy answer
my question well that's how you're gonna
be numb it's not gonna answer your
question at all do you think they will
dumb down Thanos power Dennis's power in
the MCU
no I don't think so I think I think
people were so hyped for Thanos they
were so excited to see Thanos the Thanos
was gonna be every bit as awesome in the
most cinematic universe as we want to
see in the comics now here's the real
kicker here's a word the real question
read Lantern hold vs. Red Lantern
Wolverine imagine a Red Lantern
Wolverine like Wolverine with rage I
think I think the way they're gonna
introduce Thanos the way they're gonna
have them confront heroes it's going to
gradually increase I think initially
it'll just be Thanos by himself cuz
usually here's the kicker guys we don't
have any scale for Thanos we don't know
how big fan OSA is compared to everybody
else all we saw was Thanos was just
sitting in his chair it could be fan oh
this is like 10 feet tall and he is
massive in scope that he's twice the
size of the Incredible Hulk it could be
he's the same size the Incredible Hulk
or maybe even smaller we're not really
sure yet
but I think that they'll we'll see that
nose fighting superheroes with just a
nose and then we'll see him taking on
gyms or I guess taking on what stands
for the stones and then eventually
becoming you know becoming like the
Infinity Gauntlet Thanos and infinity
war Rob I want to start reading x-min
and Inhumans where do I start
okay for those of you guys in the chat
who want to start getting into him
Inhumans there's a handful of stories
the current run of the Inhumans is
called inhuman and that is the the the
introduction of new humans but the
problem here is Marvel's building on old
stuff so I would say in this order read
Inhumans vol 2 by Paul Jenkins and Jay
Lee that's one of the best stories of
the Inhumans you can search the
Wikipedia to find out how the Inhumans
actually came about it's not the most
stellar thing everywhere you just watch
my video about the Inhumans I don't give
you the origin of where the Inhumans
came from but definitely read apology
isn't jelly's 1998 Inhumans volume to
read infinity because infinity deals
with the Inhumans and why it is we lead
to the story inhuman which is a current
run and then you could jump into inhuman
now there are some other stories of
feature the Inhumans but they're not
wildly important you have the war of
Kings you have the realm of Kings but
those are mostly care mostly stories
that involve the Inhumans that are based
around the Inhumans but they're not
required reading they're just kind of
fun to read but you could you could
really go from there with regard to the
x-men the x-men are a little more
complex here the orders of the x-men are
well known so you're really don't need
to start with the origins I would say
jump into God loves man kills which is a
really good graphic novel by Chris
Claremont
that room that wasn't Christian claim
yeah yeah Chris Claremont
that's what x-men 2 is based off of I
would say check out mmm
there's some great stories in x-men but
I'm trying to pick the stories that
matter the most for continuity because
they have a really really long
continuity um
God loves man cuz was a good win Days of
Future past is a good one um I would say
refresh yourself on Age of Apocalypse
it's not really necessary
read es for extinction that's only three
issues it's new x-men issues 114 through
116 that's
Grant Morrison's run on the x-men that
deals with Cassandra Nova's appearance
and her wiping out 16 million mutants in
Genosha the House of M is a good one and
then Messiah Complex Messiah War Hope
Summers and the twelve lights and or I
guess it's called generation Hope and
and that's that's where you could stop
if you really wanted to but again with
Secret Wars coming out you have
expedited and so you really don't really
need to read off and if you didn't want
to but they're great stories to read
just to really have fun reading about
the x-men let's see
his black bolts still not talking how do
you do a movie on that
um yeah black bolts so doesn't talk
Medusa talks for him and you could
easily do a movie about that you didn't
we don't have black bolt talk I think
it'd be cool I think it'd be see here's
here's the thing Vin Diesel would have
to act through his through his body he
that Hughes body language to act and
that would be a real test of skill for
how well of an actor that he is but
again the actress who plays Medusa would
be the one that'll really have to step
into the roles like she'll really be the
main star that movie to be honest should
be the one that brings in the most
attention now question who should play
the role of a do so I've been thinking
about this I've been thinking what
actress would be good enough to play the
role of Medusa it's still pretty
good-looking in terms of her age and
could still be effective in and being
active to a degree not necessarily like
fighting per se getting in like these
great big huge conflicts but still be
pretty effective and I haven't found one
yet
Robin bite pin I think or I guess Robin
Wright would have been really good
actors to play Medusa when she was
younger but now I think that that her
her age may be kind of a hindrance there
but the Congress I think was an
indication of the fact that even with
her age she's still a fantastic actress
so I don't know
well Adam warlock up here in the MCU yes
I can almost guarantee he will I don't
know why he wouldn't Adam warlock would
definitely be there I mean we know he's
gonna be there there's all this hype
built around his character his cocoon
broke open and guardians of the galaxy
so Rob do you think there will be any
truth to the claims that Secret Wars
might last a few months how long do you
think we'll be in this event as far as I
know Secret Wars is going to last like
six months so I'm pretty sure those
truth of that claim if you could do any
x-men from the 90s who would do if I
could be any x-men from the 90s I'm like
really like who would I do if I could be
any expert from the 90s who would I be
um Nimrod no he was an x-man [ __ ] cuz
their mother was a really cool Sentinel
probably Bishop Bishop was a great
character
what Secret Wars comic are you looking
forward to the most
I'm hyped for vows renewed I'm hyped for
a years of Future Passed
I really want to see how that story
progresses I really want to see what
happens with it but again I don't know I
mean it could be it could be totally
different okay so so jumping to
germany's twitter for a second what is
your take on david tennant the Tenth
Doctor playing zebediah killgrave the
purple man I think he'll be a fantastic
purple man he looks the part like he can
look outright crazy when he wants to so
I think he'll be able to play the role
pretty well in terms of of him playing
the character long-term I don't see it I
see him playing the the purple man
short-term but only because the problem
a misunderstood istic character I
couldn't see him as a long-term
character I think people would find him
too extreme unless they tone him down in
which case that could be reasonable and
and David Tennant could definitely play
him for the long term but either way
he'll be a great version of the purple
man we'll finally be on Guardians 2
since she's a daughter of quasar acting
as a connection to Captain Marvel I
don't know um I'd be curious to see if
that's the case I'd be curious to see if
if that's what they choose to do
I really wasn't the biggest fan of Hana
fell just didn't really care about her
that much but then again you know after
I guess with Captain Marvel with with
Marvel bringing me into I guess the
Captain Marvel world I loved his
character but I think Harold Danvers was
the best version of Captain Marvel so I
really didn't didn't really wasn't too
interested in file of Elsa the way it
really doesn't matter to me whether she
shows up or not because I'm just not to
enter what I watch a fear itself' based
movie no I wouldn't know I would not
watch for yourself
can you explain incursions a little more
um I mean I don't know I mean what will
cover like some of the stuff that goes
on between the end of incursions and the
current events and time
we'll talk about that but for right now
I mean I don't know what else I could
explain who might be the oh um David
Tennant might be playing or he's playing
the purple man in Jessica Jones as a
solo series let's see
captain britain plus mi 13 in the MCU um
I don't know why they bring in Captain
Britain there's been no indication that
they were bringing Captain Britain I
don't even don't think how the writes to
him now that I think about it I have no
idea
should Marvel reboot a new universe
concept that's what they're doing or
Secret Wars I think Rob can you do an
Ironman Superman video I was watching
throne of Atlantis and I just looked at
the character in a John Henry that was a
worker oh okay you're talking about okay
you're talking about Steel is who you're
talking about that's that's what that
character's name is um I don't know
maybe I'm not really sure if I wanted to
do him let's see what is your take on
the attack on Titan Marvel crossover I
shouldn't read it so I don't know
Aquaman is just a copy of name war I'm
not really I mean one influence the
other but it's I mean I don't think so
is mistress death going to appear in the
MCU I hope so like I really really hope
so because mistress death is a major
player in in Thanos's role like she's
her and phantoms were intertwined
you know inexorably in terms of Thanos
his destiny and why he does what he does
so I really hope she does appear like I
really hope she shows up um let's see
can you explain the Genosha massacre or
tell me where to jump where telling
where to jump into moon night comics
okay the Genosha massacre was a 40s for
extinction nets new x-men issues 114
through 116 that was Grant Morrison
taking over x-men and all Grant Morrison
did was had the series remembered and so
it just jumped from from from the
original x-men to new x-men
and instead of it being issue number one
like new expedition number one its new
x-men 114 so that's that's that's why a
lot of people just hate Grant Morrison
for that because he's screwed up the
numbering or he's screwed up the naming
and just kind of confuse people a little
bit so it would've been a lot easier for
x-men vol 2 to end or I guess for x-men
and for him to just jump in and do new
x-men let's see the only things I've
read by Alan Moore are The Killing Joke
and the crooked world from Marvel UK
with Matcham Jasper's aside from that I
haven't read anything by Alan Moore I
would though I think it'd be fun to read
League of Extraordinary Gentlemen I
actually didn't realize it was a comic
book I thought it was just a movie
Mayson like a novel or something like
that but it makes sense that it would be
based on a on a graph I assume as a
graphic novel that it was based off of
do you think Hamill will be introduced
after ordering or not in Xmen apocalypse
I hope he's introduced but I don't think
he will be I think it'd be great to
bring him in but I don't think we'll see
him let's see a comic movie you want to
see but we'll never happen oh god this
century I want to see a century film I
doubt we'll ever get one but I would
love to see a century movie let's see
who do I think would win only one can
over your kid Deadpool kid Deadpool
because he has a healing factor
definitely
but even then like he's still just
beastly I think Silver Surfer beats
Superman any day let's see I don't think
the Silver Surfer fought Superman no
only he did I don't know maybe I doubt
it though I think Superman will be able
to take him how long will this go on for
probably a couple more minutes the one
this morning was 45 minutes this was
about an hour so I figured that rounds
it out to about to close to two hours
which i think is reasonable but hey Rob
if you can only buy one comic book a
month what would you recommend DC oh um
Batman
I think Scott Steiners run on Batman is
pretty fantastic and truth I think
pretty much everything else is going on
new 52 pales in comparison to Batman's
current run with Scott Snyder I think
that's that's pretty much the creme de
la creme of what DC's publishing right
now in terms of their stories let's see
Superman or Thanos with the Infinity
Gauntlet Thanos with the infinity collar
definitely super merits wouldn't stand a
chance
um anyway guys we're gonna go ahead and
bring us to an end but but again check
out um check out Kapow comic book show
um again there's a link down in the
description of this video for those of
you guys who are joining in they have a
really really good series just head over
there say hey how much explain told me
to check you guys out and and look at
their content let me know what you think
and and yeah so again for those of you
guys who are just now joining us mmm
there will not be a video tomorrow
because we've had three videos today and
we've had a lot the two live streams and
we have the kid pool video so we're
definitely not going to do any more
videos and we're going to tone that down
tomorrow will be a break day for me
because I'll be cleaning up my apartment
today and getting dinner and so on and
then on Tuesday we'll have the podcast
and then I'm debating as to whether or
not I'll put a video again on Tuesday
but we'll see and then on Wednesday
we'll get back into it so um with that
being said you guys are awesome thanks
for coming out and and yeah so I'll
catch you guys later peace